I hate intros and especially this one
mm-hmm
Dungey need AI warm on tomorrow no wha
machi got that oh no thought I cast
season one sick name bro had a blast
butchering that for the last hour we
kick things off with the quick
explanation of how gods came down to
this world to live like normal people
because apparently it's boring being a
god they aren't allowed to use their
power except to give blessings which
allow people to fight with monsters if a
guy gives you a blessing then you become
a part of their family and their servant
the main character Belle is introduced
as he is chased by a Minotaur through a
dungeon as he gets cornered ice
Palestine a hot blonde and his new love
interest saves him he leaves without
talking to where he goes to see his
advisor I had to ask about his new crush
she tells him that she's parted the Loki
family currently level 5 and supposedly
the best sorts person in not audio since
he's in the Hestia family and only level
1 with no D ants to slide into it's
unlikely that they're gonna end up
together plenty ahead Tommy's greeted by
his goddess Hestia and if she was real I
would be a devout follower as well but
she isn't so here we are
well upgrading his stats has to you
realizes he got a new skill but hides it
from him it lets him level up faster and
the stronger his feelings are the
stronger the effects the next day he
runs into a mamey him see out who works
at a tavern and Gibson some food because
life is on easy mode when you're hot
after his dungeon run he grows rapidly
because of how strong his feelings are
fries he goes back to the tavern later
that night and just so happens to see
ice walk in with her party but they
starts talking about him and makes fun
of how he had to run from the Minotaur
this makes him want to get stronger so
he leaves embarrassin heads to the
dungeon to get more training
he episode two he goes back to the
tavern the next day to pay his bill
since he split into her than that before
co-taught apparently vouched for him to
help him get off easy shortly out of the
kindness of her heart and not because
the main characters hot and needs a hair
we jump over to a party all the guts are
sore and where we are introduced to some
new faces
we have fideo who has Thea doesn't seem
to be a fan of an Loki who was the
goddess device the reason has he has at
the party is to ask if Isis to help make
a weapon for a bell since he is in
desperate need of an upgrade it takes a
lot of begging but eventually if Isis
comes around and helps make the weapon
personally the next day Bell is
approached by Anya Primeau who works at
the tavern with Siri she asks him to
bring C at her wallet at monster philia
which is a monster taming event held
each year what idea is talking to Loki
about how she saw Belle and is starting
to give off some serious stalker vibes
Belle goes to monster filly and just so
happens to run into Hester who just got
back from making his weapon but ie
releases a monster and tells it to chase
Belle in Hestia Belle tries to protect
Hestia but his trash sword breaks so in
the last scene he's preparing to
sacrifice himself to buy her some time
episode three we find out the bells
grandpa had died to a monster and that's
what made Belle want to become an
adventurer he goes out to find a family
to join but nobody wants him because
he's so weak until he runs into Hestia
back to the president's revealed that
his new weapon gets stronger as he gets
stronger so when he combined it with his
new skill it sounds like an Opie build
word gets around that multiple monsters
have escaped so ice and Loki go around
slaying them to help out
Hestia who was separated from Belle
comes back to find Belle still running
from the monster she gives him his new
knife and upgrade says thats one more
time which is apparently enough to
square up with train rats in win and II
happened to score some brownie points
because I just happened to be walking by
and saw the whole thing
after the fight has Thea passes out and
he brings her back to the tavern for a
place to stay Hestia wakes up and they
have a moment or whatever and then we
jump over to a douchebag verbally
abusing to support who is clearly
ignoring the incumbered alert episode 4
ina throws in her application to the
harem when she goes shopping with Belle
for new armor they go to the Hephaestus
shop where all the armors way too
expensive until they get to the top
floor there are a lot of new blacksmiths
who want their work to be evaluated so
they sell their Armour for cheap he ends
up buying a new chess piece made by
wealth crows oh and also gets armor as a
gift from ina well heading home he runs
into the support man from last episode
Lily who was running from her toxic air
Belle protects her embryo deters things
from escalating but Lily leaves before
they can talk to her the next day Lily
finds him to ask if she can support him
and he fondles her ears they end up
doing a dungeon run together and
afterwards when talking I and as she
points out that his knife is gone he
thinks he dropped it but in reality Lily
had stolen it which is probably why the
other adventurer was chasing her as well
she tries to sell it but it's actually a
really weak weapon unless Belle is using
it Breo walks by and notices that she
has the knife and takes it away so Lily
starts running well fleeing she runs
into Belle and briault follow soon after
reira turns the knife by ends up not
riding on Lily she continues to support
for him and his caught off guard when he
splits the loot fifty-fifty with her
episode 5 Lily is getting kicked around
by some guys who apparently shows money
to well in the dungeon the next day lily
uses a magic item to protect Belle and
is continuously surprised by how well he
treats her they take the next day off
and see how to suggest reading a book
about magic that was left behind by
somebody in the tavern the next time has
two upgrades of stat she notices that he
learned magic it turns out that book
happened to be a grimoire which gave him
magic abilities he's so excited to learn
magic that he goes to the dungeon to try
it out he over does a and gets affected
by mine zero which happens when you use
too much magic and you pass out Isis
company back from a boss fight with
everybody and they find him unconscious
she feels bad about that they making fun
of him so she gives
Milou and this is what I mean when I say
hot guys are playing on easy mode when
he wakes up his beta flares up and he
runs out without saying anything
yep asoto
we get some backstory on Lily about how
her parents died in the dungeon so she
had to become a support to survive her
whole life adventures have been treating
her like trash so she grew to hate them
and it finds out that the Sohma family
that Lily is a part of is addicted to
alcohol and they are known to screw
people over to get their fix which
explains why they keep on taking her
money on the next run globally convinces
Belle to try going to the 10th floor
which he agrees to it's a trap though so
she could still his knife again and she
uses monster lures to keep him
distracted while she makes her escape
well leaving she runs into the adventure
that she had stolen for him before and
he was all Chris Brown on it gone away
Belle way double-crosses in those so
that he could take all of her stuff
instead David were in killer ads and one
of them ends up killing many Chris Brown
good no way and his companions make off
with most of her stuff and leave Lilly
there to die
luckily ina knew something was up and
asked ice to help them ice killed all
the yogurts on the 10th floor without
anybody seeing her which allowed Belle
to go help Lilly just in time he ends up
forgiving Lily for screwing him over
again and gets his knife back during the
fight he had lost the guard that I had
given to him when they went shopping and
ice finds out on the 10th floor
he episode 7 Lilly joins the Hestia
family and the harem to fight over Belle
Belle goes to the guild hall where he
sees Ines with ice so he tries to escape
to avoid talking to them he is stopped
by a Glory's face play and finally has
to sit down to have a proper
conversation with ice she returns to
guard that he had lost and after talking
for a bit offers to help teach him to
fight they meet upon a wall to Train
where he gets humiliated every time
[Music]
meanwhile though that is under orders
from Freya to train a Minotaur and make
it stronger
Bella is able to clear the 10th floor
dungeon now thanks to his training and
the rest of the episode his harem
fillers Yepez o date Belle finds out the
ice is a bit of a badass because she's
level 6 now and defeated a floor 37 boss
by herself
they have to stop their training
sessions though because the Loki family
is going on an expedition into the
dungeon their goal is to get to the 59th
floor which has never been done before
well on a dungeon run the Minotaur that
was trained by with that is released and
Belle comes face to face with it
it attacks and Lily gets knocked out so
Belle has to hold it off until she wakes
up go lucky family get word from some
injured adventurers that there is a
Minotaur on the loose on the ninth floor
and that Belle is fighting it as soon as
she hears this ice brushes to aid him
Lilly wakes up and is ordered by Belle
to run away then his arm gets impaled by
the Minotaur Soren he looks like he's
out of it but ice comes in once again to
save him he's too proud though and
doesn't want to have to rely on her
again so he prepares to fight the
Minotaur by himself he faces off with
the Minotaur and impresses everybody in
the Loki family well spamming fireball
he mind zeros and passes out
this gives everybody else a chance to
look at his stats and he has all s-rank
abilities
yep the sewed 9 after being level 1 for
just month and a half Bell earned level
2 from the Minotaur fight even ice was
level 1 for over a year so everybody is
talking about him and how fast he
leveled up he also got a new skill
called Argonaut but isn't sure what it
does with his level up also came a new
nickname little rookie which sounds like
a trash Disney movie ryu messes up a guy
in a bar fight because he was picking on
them the next day bell happens to run
into the guy who made the armor that he
bought wealth Kuro so they make a deal
to party up and an exchange wealth will
only make weapons and armor for belt
scissor and a party now they head to the
11th floor dungeon and while their bells
hand starts to glow when a massive
monster shows up he uses fireball and at
one shot this was the work of his
Argonaut skill which gives some of the
possibility to overcome any difficulty
and one-shot an enemy which sounds so
broken we learned that well fee used to
be a part of a famous blacksmithing
family but doesn't want to make magic
items anymore even though that's what
they were known for and the last couple
of scenes he makes bail a new dagger
from the Minotaur torn that he had
defeated before episode 10 talking
mikazuki family members head into the
middle floors where Bell and the others
are - Oda misses wanting to meet with
Bell but it's not revealed why we're
talking mikazuki family members get
injured and are fleeing a pack of
monsters they lure them into Belle's
party and use them as a distraction to
escape Bell and the others try running
away but I end up getting chased further
into the dungeon the panties do flag
give the news to has to you I try to
rally a rescue party but a Mason has he
I both want to tag along even though
it's against the rules forgot to go into
the dungeon they also convinced Rio to
come along since she used to be a
stronger Venturer nobody uses the
monster repel item to keep monsters off
of them but when it runs out they're
faced with four minotaurs Belle is able
to kill one and uses his Argonauts kill
to defeat the other three but looks
exhausted afterwards
episode 11 the rescue party find
remnants of their fight and are getting
closer to Belle they decide that Belle
and the others probably went further
into the dungeon so that they could get
to floor 18 where there are safe zones
welven Lily both pass out leaving Belle
to be the literal carry of the group
which is unfortunate timing because
they're in the attack on titan crossover
episode but thanks to poor level design
they slip past the floor boss once they
make it to floor 18 who defy ice is
there to help them Finn is in charge and
explains that some of their members were
poisoned so they sent back a couple of
others to the surface to get an antidote
before they can continue wellthen Lily
wake up and ice shows the first signs of
jealousy call up the ship's boys he's in
the rescue party finally arrives so
everybody is reunited and wealth gets a
mystery item with a message from Ephesus
everybody's going to head back
loke members are ready to move which
will be in two days so they get a free
day off where Bell and ice talk about
going to a town in the dungeon episode
12 everyone heads out to the town levira
battle ends up running into morta the
guy that Rio messed up at the bar and
they're holding a grudge we get some
fanservice baths peeking and that's some
lorem Rio Curran bell go to the grave of
her previous family who were all killed
by a trap set by other adventurers Rio
is blacklisted and the guilts because
she killed all the other adventures that
set the trap then naturally became a
mate ice and most of the other low-key
members leave ahead of the second group
SES kidnapped by mortal and Belle's
forced to 1v1 him to get her back
but he ends up cheating using an
invisibility at him that amis had given
to him to teach Belle about the dark
side of people sucking mikazuki members
and whop show up to help him out while
Lily releases Hestia side note welp
drops the mystery item that has Feist
escaped to him like a bot sto releases
her divine power to ensure that Belle
isn't hurt by he was actually holding
his own just fine and finally the
season's last boss starts to show up
with an ominous intro the episode 13 the
attack on titan boss falls through the
roof and everybody including the
townspeople have to fight it the mage is
charged up a big hit and that's when
they realized that the time regenerating
powers are even stronger than Eddins
they'll use this Argonaut to blow its
head off which doesn't work gets knocked
out brollies with the big-ass sword and
charges Argonaut again guess there's no
cooldown so we can assume the gods are
actually right does failing at balancing
their world - everyone hits it with
their strongest attacks including wealth
who uses the magic weapon that have Isis
sent him Bal KS is the Titan and they go
back to get drunk where organs of the
sexual nature continue to be blocked oh
and apparently by azusa's grandson
the roof and everybody including the
time everyone else's yet now Belle uses
our sorry bit stronger than I meant then
edit drunker than ed hidden edits but I
need to go back together you think it'd
be good to get a good way to get a good
to give you get the bacon that's when
they realized that the time we're gonna
tell you doesn't work the attack on
Titan boss falls through the roof and
everybody including the townspeople have
to fight it the mage is charged up a big
hit and that's when they realized that
the time regenerating powers are even
stronger than Eddins they'll use this
Argonaut to blow its head off which
doesn't work gets knocked out brollies
with the big-ass sword and charges
Argonaut again
guess there's no cooldown so we can
assume the gods are actually right does
failing at balancing their world -
everyone hits it with their strongest
attacks including wealth who uses the
magic weapon that have Isis sent him Bal
KS is the Titan and they go back to get
drunk where organs of the sexual nature
continue to be blocked oh and apparently
by azusa's grandson